was singled out by this man he joins us
now to respond
senator i appreciate you coming on
tonight this makes me genuinely nervous
that someone like this could have any
control over the so-called security
at the u.s capitol or in washington or
in america
yeah it's it's very disturbing tucker i
mean the some of the statements that
the general has made are just downright
crazy you cited some of them i mean
saying that at least stefanik for
instance ought to be treated like a
terrorist and not allowed to fly put on
the no-fly list
also his statements about law
enforcement this is somebody who this
whole last year tucker
encouraged condoned the violent rioting
in our city
said that federal law enforcement who
were sent to portland to protect the
federal courthouse
he said that they were a mob themselves
so that they were acting like they were
serving a dictator
act attacked them for not being real
soldiers those are his words i mean it's
unbelievable it's just unbelievable and
it shows
that nancy pelosi isn't interested in
getting any facts
she's interested in power and an
amassing power and an excuse
to keep hold of power including those
thousands of troops who are still
at the capitol who are still there
treating it like an armed camp
why they no one will say but this is
what pelosi is interested in
so i i saw an internal
memo today from house republicans saying
you know we're not going to question the
presence of all those federal troops in
washington
because there is some kind of threat
which they never explained what a
betrayal of the country i would say but
beyond that
this is a guy running around calling
himself general
i mean we shouldn't we be getting a
little concerned at this point
that the the leadership of the u.s
military should be totally non-partisan
and not involved in these debates i mean
are we sure that it still is yeah well
this is somebody this particular general
who's been retired now for a while and i
don't question his service to our
country at all tucker i applaud him for
it but
he has been a a partisan a dedicated
partisan that's putting it mildly
since he left the military a an extreme
left-wing democrat
and you can just see it in the comments
that he's made but i'm concerned about
what they're laying the groundwork for
here what nancy pelosi is doing
i'm concerned that they continue to
treat the january 6 catastrophe that
criminal riot
as an excuse to seize power to control
more power to to step on people's second
amendment rights to take away their
first amendment rights
now we're hearing about a domestic war
on terror i mean what's that going to be
an excuse to go rifle through
the emails and bank statements and
personal messages of law-abiding
americans i mean this is
very very frightening stuff and what
pelosi and the democrats are doing here
trying to consolidate power
it's dangerous please convince your
fellow republicans on the hill to stand
up for the country please
i think what you said is absolutely
right it needed to be said and i hope
others will say it
thank you very much senator good to see
you